la emoción reflejada en los rostros de
estas jóvenes el 21 de febrero la corte
constitucional de Colombia sacó del
Código Penal el delito del aborto hasta
la semana 24 de gestación una decisión
histórica y El eco de la celebración es
resuena de nuevo en las calles de Bogotá
el movimiento causa justa logró que el
alto tribunal emitiera la sentencia c055
Laura Castro vocera de la organización
reconoce que se han convertido en un
ejemplo para la región en materia de
derechos para las mujeres son una
invitación o un ejemplo de cómo la
movilización feminista y el litigio
estratégico está poniendo nuevos
argumentos y nuevos discursos para
reconocer los derechos de las mujeres y
están bien una invitación a ver cada vez
más los procesos de movilización Social
del sur global desde 2006 Colombia
contaba con la sentencia c-355 el
sistema de tres causales que impera
también ahora para aquellas mujeres que
quieren interrumpir su embarazo a partir
de la semana 24
Las barreras para el acceso al aborto
siguen siendo amplias especialmente para
las mujeres Rurales y migrantes
Este es el informe no pasa por muchas
cosas que es una de las frases que nos
dijo una de las mujeres Venezolanas
entrevistada Juliana Martínez es la
autora del informe señala que una
barrera constante es la discriminación y
las violencias que sufren por ser
migrantes Las mayores barreras entre las
mujeres migrantes y regulares las viven
indudablemente las Caminantes de tener
el trayecto para acceder a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
termina siendo seguir haciéndose
recorrido solas por lo tanto más
inseguras ser dejadas atrás y eso hace
que muchas veces ellas no estén
dispuestas a realizarse el procedimiento
aún cuando es su deseo el
desconocimiento del nuevo marco legal es
otra de las problemáticas que se suma a
la xenofobia nos plantea una de las
necesidades y es tener una visión más
integral de la salud sexual y la salud
reproductiva como parte del derecho a la
salud Colombia está en la vanguardia en
derechos reproductivos pero la
despenalización social del aborto y su
acceso universal sigue siendo una
batalla de largo aliento para el
movimiento feminista